alles fängt mit einem video und wie
entdecken einen jungen mann der kinder
anschreit im netz nennen sie ihn dem
bösen onkel was steckt dahinter
hast du mich verstanden die geschichte
des bösen onkels beginnt im süden des
landes sowie chan hat 230 1000 einwohner
einer davon ist berühmt wir treffen den
bösen onkel bei einem freund der gerade
ein restaurant aufgemacht hat beide
verbindet die leidenschaft für gutes
essen und geld verdienen das geschäft
mit den kinder erschrecken versüßt ihm
sein leben
letzten monat habe ich wieder ein video
hochgeladen
mehr als zehn millionen mal wurde dieses
video geklickt
es explodierte eigentlich hat sheen
junior wie er richtig heißt einen
kleinen lieferservice aber dafür hat er
keine zeit
sein büro ist jetzt in einem
fünf-sterne-hotel dort nimmt er seine
videos auf ein live stream ist ein
bisschen laut ich muss immer schreit
wenn ich das zu hause machen würde
könnten meine eltern und großeltern
nicht schlafen
das hotelzimmer ist dagegen
schallisoliert den bösen onkel hört man
bevor man ihn sind seine stimme sein
böses gesicht sind sein markenzeichen
und so erschreckt er chinas kinder bis
sie gehorchen gruppe nicht in der nase
wenn ich dich dabei erwischen dann hole
ich dich denn deine hand ist voller
bakterien
chinas kinder sollen artig diszipliniert
und folgsam sein
das wünscht sich präsident ski den sie
onkel schienen
er braucht eine gut ausgebildete jugend
und im kampf um die weltspitze zu
triumphieren
das ist sein sozialistischer traum ich
hoffe ihr lernt die geschichte unserer
revolution und tragt sie in eurer seele
in der zwischenzeit solltet ihr schon
einiges wissen und einige fähigkeiten
besitzen die nötig sind ein großartiges
sozialistisches land aufzubauen artige
kinder schreien im chor sonst schreit
sie der böse onkel an und schont sich
dabei nicht
er muss wie ein leistungssportler auf
seine gesundheit achten
auf seinem handy bekommt er die
nachrichten von den eltern geschickt sie
schreiben ihm die erziehungsprobleme und
den namen des kindes auf dann produziert
er ein 30 sekunden video und bekommt
dafür fünf euro bis zu 600 solcher
videos schafft er am tag 3000 euro für
zehn stunden harte arbeit die arbeit
schadet meinem hals besonders wenn ich
morgens anfangen zu sprechen tut er w
aber wenn ich ein bisschen schreie dann
gewöhne ich mich schnell wieder daran
eine spezielle kräuter teemischung soll
seine ramponierten stimmen daheim spät
scheußlich
in peking wartet auf den anruf des bösen
onkels für ihren dreijährigen sohn der
kleine rennt immer weg sie hat deshalb
kein schlechtes gewissen ihrem sohn
angst zu machen er muss gehorchen lernen
damit er erfolgreich die reich gewordene
mittelschicht setzt alles daran dass
ihre kinder den sozialen aufstieg
fortsetzen
eine freundin hat mir vom bösen onkel
erzählt sie hat für ihr kind bei ihm ein
video bestellt es hat funktioniert
ich mache mir keine sorgen dass ich
meinen sohn zu sehr erschrecken
schlimmer ist doch wenn er verloren geht
der böse onkel schreit und schaut
grimmig sowie bestellt wenn du weg
grenzt wichtig doch diesmal schaffte es
nicht lacht nur das sorgt für hämische
kommentare im live stream
du hast du ja sagt schreiben sie aber
meistens klappt es mit dem erschrecken
die kinder bekommen angst und weinen
dann ging sie leer erzählt uns später er
hätte auch gerne einen bösen onkel in
seiner kindheit gehabt denn seine eltern
beim viel strenger wenn ich böse war
haben meine eltern mich gar nicht erst
erschreckt sondern gleich verdroschen
meine methode ist er besser
in seiner stadt ist er ein star weil er
in china bekannt ist
viele mütter und kinder erkennen ihn die
klein schauen ihm fast schreckhaft an
nicht immer gibt er den bösen onkel nett
sein gehört auch zu seinem repertoire
seid ihr bei der brave kinder ich tue
guten kindern nichts wie kindern ist ein
böses kind wenn er böse ist dann kann
ich ihn viele deutsche erzählen wir ihm
und dieser mutter würden nicht verstehen
dass chinesische eltern dafür zahlen
ihre kinder anschreien zu lassen
die händler sind auch alt genug zu
verstehen was falsch ist
sie haben keine probleme mit den böhsen
onkelz sie erschrecken nicht so stark
dass sie verstummen oder dass ihre seele
einen schaden bekommt kinderschreck und
kinderfreund beides will der böse onkel
von china seien in dem land in dem
anschreiben schon ein fortschritt ist
[Musik]